new CBS News poll finds more than half
of Americans think the environment will
be worse for the next generation it also
found that 59% of Americans believe
humanity can do something to stop
climate change and that is why we are
continuing the tradition started by
Walter Cronkite 49 years ago to mark
Earth Day in a special broadcast this
morning we will take you to every
continent to look at modern challenges
and unique solutions from high emissions
in London and air pollution in India to
water concerns in New Mexico and
Australia and deforestation problems in
the Amazon it's all part of our special
earth matters broadcast this morning a
day set aside for a nationwide
outpouring of mankind seeking its own
survival day on April 22nd 1970 CBS News
marked the first-ever earth day with a
special report anchored by Walter
Cronkite the gravity of the message of
Earth Day still came through and instead
of forever
the view often stops with haze CBS News
correspondent reported on protests
cleanup efforts and calls to action from
all over the country if we don't do
something about it it's just going to
get worse it was the start of the modern
environmental movement seeing the
riverbed like this doesn't worry you now
49 years later we're covering the
environmental issues of the day what's
happening now isn't natural that it's
caused by human activity
this time from every corner of the globe
we're gonna climb this tower we're in
the Amazon rainforest in South America
where deforestation threatens everything
from the plants and animals to the
indigenous tribes who live there if you
need a taxi in New Delhi you get into
one of
we'll take you to New Delhi India one of
the most polluted cities in the world
and we'll meet the young people of South
Africa leading a renewable energy
revolution for all generation climate
change is obvious you're not only
experience it but we're not threatened
by what it means in terms of change in
the ways of doing business in order to
to respond to that on the first Earth
Day Walter Cronkite told viewers that
cleaning up our planet would require
personal involvement and sacrifice those
who ignored Earth Day well that's one
thing those who ignore the crisis of our
planet that's quite another I'm so glad
we're doing this
this is just to show everybody there's
something we can all do that's right
Thank You Walter yes